-This is great. I mean,
you've been on the show
since the pandemic started,
but you were just
a disembodied head
and it's so great
to be reminded that you
have a whole human body.
-Allegedly.
-But yes.
Yes. I know.
Last time we talked,
I was crashing
on my friend's couch in L.A.
We were Zooming.
I was in like a velvet onesie
and, now, I can't breathe
in a leather skirt.
-Do you do you enjoy
having a reason
to get dressed up again?
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, good.
-I mean, I don't know about you,
but I started --
a couple months ago,
I started like,
even if I'd go
to the grocery store,
I'd throw on mascara,
-No, same thing.
-Same with you, yeah.
Which, in the moment,
feels good
and then, you get home
and you're like --
[ Inhales sharply ]
Ah, it's kind of missing
the little...
-Right.
-oomph of like going out,
but, yeah.
-Sure.
You were in L.A.,
as you mentioned.
You're back in the city,
You've been back in the city
this year.
How do you feel?
Because I am feeling
very bullish about New York.
-Bullish?
-Yeah, like I'm feeling
positive about it, you know...
-Yes.
-...upbeat, optimistic.
-I thought you were like,
"I'm feeling like I want
to run at it and gore it."
[ Laughter ]
-I want to take it apart.
-[ Laughing ] Take it apart.
I'm feeling very hopeful.
I rode the subway
for the first time.
I wept.
-You did?!
-I did.
-On the subway?
-Yeah.
Because I couldn't believe
that it's been over a year
and I couldn't believe
that like we're all --
we're slowly getting back to,
I don't know,
like the New York
that I fell in love with,
you know, when I moved here,
and even the New York
that I grew up watching.
And, obviously,
it's different, but.
Like the other day,
I went with a friend.
We rode the Staten Island Ferry
-Look at you.
-just to ride it.
[ Laughs ]
-My takeaway here is that
you were away
for just long enough
that you've come back a tourist
who is here for the first time.
-That's pretty much
what happened
because I got here in December
and I was like, "What?"
Because it was just in time
for like two blizzards
and no one to leave
and it was a nightmare here.
And we were riding
the Staten Island Ferry
the other day and then,
when we got off,
like in the downtown --
I don't know where that is,
but like where the thing goes --
a woman almost ran me over
with her bike
and she was like, "Move!"
And I was like,
"We're coming back!
Like look at that!"
-Wait, so had you ever ridden
the Staten Island Ferry before?
-Oh, yeah.
-You had?
-I like it.
-Gotcha.
-Because you see everything.
-No, I mean, I would imagine.
I, obviously, am revealing
here that I have not.
-Oh, it's a ball.
I mean, is it a ball?
It's a ball.
-Gotcha.
And so do you get off
in Staten Island --
-Yeah, and then,
you just like...
♪ Doot doot doot doot ♪
...you like do, do, do-do-loo
through the lobby
and then, you get back on,
you ride it again. [ Laughs ]
-Wow!
-it's great like
if you want to be --
like those moments
when you feel like
you're like a tourist
in your own hometown.
Like my friend and I rode it.
We ate snacks.
We like sat on the back
and looked at the skyline.
That was the rail.
And we were like,
"We live here.
This is so majestic."
Because, right now,
we're all like inside.
We're scared.
We're on our phones.
-That is so lovely.
-It was really lovely.
And it's open air.
-I don't mean to go back
too far,
but did anyone on the subway
notice you were crying about it?
-[ Laughs ] No, I hope not.
-Yeah.
-The crying I was doing,
it was gentle.
It was like very like
"The Crown."
I was like gazing out...
-Oh.
-...like just like it wouldn't
break the water line.
-I think every character
on "The Crown" would also cry,
if they were
on the New York City subway.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
Like stoically,
as like orchestra like swelled
and there was like a slow push.
-Something went terribly wrong
when the queen visited New York
and ended up on the subway.
-And she ended up
on the subway, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-You have a wonderful new show
-Thank you.
-and I want to talk about --
This is the first scene
you filmed.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-So, you basically like burst
-Forth.
-out of the ground.
-I burst out from the desert,
from the ground,
and it looks like
it's like a --
It's a beautiful shot,
but I'm like blasted
from the earth
through a water main.
-Now, this was not like --
Excuse me.
This was not special effects
that mean you did not have
to be submerged in water?
-No. They drove us
to the desert,
where they had buried
-You're doing a lot
of desert work recently.
-I know, there's
a lot desert work.
I know.
-I mean, "Palm Springs"
was fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Such good desert work from you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Obviously, they saw it
and they're like,
"She's our preeminent
desert actress."
-Yeah. They were like,
"Let's see
what else we can do
to her out there."
By the way, is that Andy
and does it say,
"My doink fell off!"?
-Yes. This is your costar
Andy Samberg,
saying, "My doink fell off!"
-His doink fell off.
Okay.
He played a very popular
oc-curring character...
[ Laughter ]
...who was a mummy.
And this is now available
-Okay.
-in the NBC Experience Store,
which is not currently open.
-Can I see the picture?
-Of his face?
-Yeah, his eyes are closed.
-[ Laughing ]
That's so funny.
-He played a mummy on the show,
whose doink fell off.
-Wow.
-Would you believe,
having spent time with him,
that he wrote the line,
"My doink fell off!"
-God, would I believe that.
[ Laughter ]
Andy Samberg?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
the Andy Samberg.
-This guy?
-Our preeminent doink actor.
[ Laughter ]
This is how you had to sit.
-Yes. So they drove me
to the desert,
where they'd buried a tank
of water in the ground.
-Yeah. I think
that's a better example.
-Yes.
-So they buried, okay.
-So, then,
they had me get in the tank
with our incredible
stunt coordinator, Katie Rowe.
-So you're not in there alone.
-I'm not in there alone.
-That's Katie there.
-That's Katie there and she's
in full scuba gear
with like a breathing tank.
And then, you can see,
in that one,
that's like how much air
I have to breathe,
but that's when the light
is cracked.
So, then, they shut the lid
and you're just in darkness
and you're like here.
-Right.
-And then, they bury you alive.
They put dirt on it.
-Oof!
-So you hear like,
"Ph-th, ph-th."
And there's a little
walkie-talkie in there.
And underneath me is a grate
and underneath the grate
is many jets.
Like -- [ Laughs ]
-I mean, it's really impressive.
-It's crazy.
-Because you seem like --
Are you not someone
who gets claustrophobic?
-I am.
-You are?!
-Yeah. This was like
a nightmare.
-Yeah.
-But it's also fun.
Well, I couldn't help
but feel, the whole time,
I was like, "Wow, look at me!
-Yeah.
-I'm in a movie!"
Like it felt -- because there
was like a crane shot
and then, on the walkie,
they'd be like, "3, 2,"
and then the jets would go
and then they would blast me
out of the hole
and like it was 40°
because the desert,
turns out, it's cold.
-That's how they getcha.
That's how the desert gets you.
-That's how the desert gets you.
You like learned about it
watching those
Bugs Bunny cartoons.
It was never cold.
-Never cold.
You think a bunch of roadrunners
are going to be your friends.
You get there
and you freeze your ass off.
Yeah, it's terrible.
And they would blast me out
and then we had
to do it like 20 times.
I do look very happy
in that photo, I think,
because I'm like, "Look at me!
Doing stunts."
-You were like,
-But it was terrifying.
-"Let's do this one,
for if I'm ever
on a talk show about it."
-"Oh, I'll file this away
for the talk show."
No, but then, because you're
in filthy water --
You can see it
in the other picture.
-Yeah, we do have a good --
I think this is
the filthy water shot.
-You can see like
there's like dead bugs
and there's like gross stuff.
And then, I got a terrible rash
from the filthy water.
-Well, what a wonderful --
-And the scene is in the show
for, mm, seven seconds?
-Is it really?
-I think so.
But it's beautiful!
And it felt really cool.
-This is a show about --
It's about people connecting
via chips in their head,
-Yeah.
-to be more connected to,
I guess, their partners.
-Well, to their partner.
-Both: Yeah.
-My character is married
to this like sort of
Elon Musk-like tech wiz recluse.
I don't know if Elon Musk
is a recluse.
He doesn't seem like it, but.
-I think he's pretty out there.
-Actually, he does seem like
he goes out a lot.
-I mean, not right now.
Everybody's a little bit
of a recluse.
But there's the wonderful
Ray Romano...
-Ugh!
-...who is just the best.
-The best.
-He plays your father
and his wife on the show
really steals it
because she is played by,
I guess --
what would you call it?
-Synthetic partner.
That's great.
-[ Laughs ] Your eyes.
You're like, "Okay."
-That wasn't what I was
going to say.
-Yeah, sure.
You were going to say sex doll.
-Sex doll,
but this is really fun.
The author of the book
that it's based on --
-Yeah, Alissa Nutting,
who's a genius.
-She cast the synthetic partner.
-Well, that's her face,
because you got to pay
for the rights to someone's
face, if you're going
to be putting them
on a synthetic partner
on TV.
-Is that a true story?
-That's a true story.
So they were like, "Well,
we can hire someone and pay them
for the rights to their face."
She was like,
"Or I could do it for free."
-Wow.
-And so, that's Hollywood.
-Then, we can save money
for our tank stunt.
-To blast Cristin out
in a filthy tank of water.
-Hey, thank you for --
Filthy Tank of Water
was originally
what they were going to call
the Staten Island Ferry.
-I know. That's right.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
This is a terrible --
This is like --
I'm trying to like
"Yes, and," you right now
and, instead, my brain was like,
"We've been inside watching TV.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, abort, abort,
[ Laughter ]
run away, run away, run away,"
and I was like --
And then they made it
the Staten Island Ferry.
That's when the -- Uh-oh.
-This is fine.
There's no audience here
to know
if that went well or not.
-Yeah, I don't know.
We'll leave it up
to the Internet to decide.
You know, the Internet,
that fair
and kind place.
-Yeah, fair and balanced.
Hey, thank you for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-It's always a delight
to see you.
-Yeah, delightful.
"Made for Love"
is streaming on HBO Max
and, if you're
on the Staten Island Ferry,
-[ Laughs ]
-you can also see her.